[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a una semana en el
mundo del programa de France 24 en el
que los periodistas son los invitados y
conversamos de una manera más
distensionada sobre algunos de los
hechos más relevantes de la semana para
conversar sobre la selección de temas
que tenemos para el día de hoy hemos
invitado a Laura Bonilla periodista y
subdirectora de la fundación pares en
América Latina Laura Bienvenida al
programa Gracias por estar con nosotros
y cómo termina usted la semana bueno
Muchas gracias por invitarnos pues muy
contenta por poder hablar con temas
internacionales hablar de temas
internacionales contigo Pues porque en
América Latina Esta semana he estado
cargadísima de noticias Sí muchas
noticias alrededor del mundo diría yo
pero América Latina estuvo en la lupa
también con muchísimos temas Pues
también saludamos a temories Greco él es
periodista y documentalista se conecta
desde la Ciudad de México temories
gracias por estar con nosotros y cómo
termina usted su semana
Hola hola Pues muy bien Buenas tardes
Pues muy bien aquí en México también el
año empezó con muchísima energía con
muchísimas actividades y bueno ahora
este ya estamos en febrero Pero subo
pero Encadenados rumbo a las elecciones
que vamos a tener el próximo año pero
que todo se ha adelantado en este país
ahora
pues ustedes también nos pueden
acompañar con sus opiniones y
comentarios y también sus preguntas por
supuesto a través de las redes sociales
nos encuentran en arroba
franz24_s@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo la etiqueta es
numeral una semana en el mundo f24 todo
junto todo pegado para que dejen sus
comentarios y sus preguntas pues
avanzamos entonces al primer tema que
tenemos el mundo entero centró la mirada
a lo largo de esta semana en Turquía y
en Siria a raíz de ese terremoto que
sacudió a estos dos países causando
miles de Muertos e incalculables daños
en Materiales en diferentes ciudades de
esos dos países los equipos de búsqueda
y de rescate enviados por diferentes
países del mundo se hicieron presentes
allí en las diferentes ciudades turcas y
sirias para atender la emergencia
Lamentablemente con el paso de las horas
pues se reducen las posibilidades de
encontrar a más personas con vida bajo
los escombros de los edificios este
terremoto tiene lugar en un momento de
coyuntura muy particular por ejemplo
para el caso Turco este país está
prácticamente o teóricamente podemos
decir en plena campaña presidencial
ya se han presentado algunos de los
candidatos para la primera el primer
cargo político de ese país el actual
mandatario
se juega su reelección la forma de como
enfrente esta emergencia puede
beneficiarle Para obtener más votos y
sin duda alguna Pues el tema de la
reconstrucción del sureste de Turquía se
va a convertir en un tema de campaña
entre tanto Siria sigue inmersa en un
conflicto con zonas completamente
capturadas por diferentes bandos la
infraestructura completamente arrasada y
Los Rebeldes que están controlando
algunos puntos importantes pues se
enfrentan al gobierno que controla otras
zonas del país y ha sido muy difícil
garantizar y enviar asistencia de ayuda
humanitaria a este país comienzo
entonces con Laura aquí en el estudio de
France 24 este terremoto obviamente
conmocionado a la comunidad
internacional pero también yo rescato
Laura la solidaridad del mundo se ha
volcado hacia Turquía de asiria por lo
menos para ayudar en estas primeras
horas que son fundamentales para
encontrar a personas con vida Sí eso es
cierto pero no tan cierto para el caso
de Siria entonces en el caso de Turquía
pues efectivamente hace parte vamos está
en la unión
Turquía es un país que recibe muchísimo
apoyo
prácticamente aldogan tiene todas las
capacidades en este momento para hacer
de esta tragedia una plataforma en su
campaña y ganar las elecciones y no es
la misma situación para Siria primero
Pues por capacidad obviamente no hay un
estado sirio
unificado que pueda recibir la ayuda
humanitaria Pero también es cierto que
tampoco ha habido tanta intención de
enviar toda la ayuda posible a las
ciudades del norte de Siria como sí lo
ha sido para Turquía incluso digamos en
la producción de imágenes en los
discursos sensibilizadores Siria parece
bastante olvidada por la comunidad
internacional en general
bueno y le preguntó a nuestro siguiente
invitado a temor y sus impresiones sobre
este terremoto que sorprendió al mundo
entero al inicio de la semana y pues nos
tiene en vilo sobre todo por la cantidad
de personas que han fallecido el conteo
es impresionante
Pues mira yo estoy en una en una en una
ciudad que ha sufrido varios terremotos
graves en el 85 y en el 17 y y aquí hay
mucha simpatía por lo que está viviendo
la gente en Turquía y en Siria pero pero
creo que lo que lo que cuesta trabajo es
me valorar las dimensiones de lo que de
lo que ha estado ocurriendo porque por
ejemplo aquí en el 17 tuvimos dos
terremotos en el mismo mes en septiembre
separados por doce días separados por
más de mil kilómetros en realidad Aunque
fueron en el mismo país el que uno no se
sintió en esta parte aquí en Ciudad de
México y aquí hubo aquí cerca no no se
sintió en el sur en la zona de Chiapas y
sobre todo esos dos terremotos
provocaron menos de cuatrocientas
fatalidades que que es terrible este nos
nos despertó de nuevo los los traumas
que que conservamos desde el más grave
que hoy fue el del 85 que tuvo tal vez
unos 20 mil Muertos pero ahora hubo
menos de y lo que tenemos ahora por
ejemplo esta esta cifra que que tenemos
en pantalla de 22.000 pues son más o
menos cincuenta y cinco veces lo que
tuvimos aquí en el 17 de ambos
terremotos además esto se agrava por el
invierno los terremotos de aquí fueron
en el en el en el en el verano y
nuestros inviernos no se parecen a lo
que tienen allá no no había nieve no
puedo imaginar lo que es estar Atrapado
entre los escombros cuando con esas
temperaturas tan tan dramáticas lo que
hace un rescatista trabajando en esas
condiciones y sobre todo la guerra la
guerra que no ha terminado en el norte
de Siria una guerra que bueno el norte
de Siria está dividido entre las zonas
controladas por el por el por el
gobierno las zonas controladas por los
grupos islamistas las controladas por el
ejército Turco y las y las controladas
por los por los kurdos y entre ellos ahí
sigue habiendo conflictos y además las
construcciones siguen dañadas o sea hace
dos dos semanas un edificio en alepo sin
que haya o sea solamente por los daños
que él tuvo durante la Guerra Entonces
eso es en Siria en Turquía pues es una
zona que que sigue estando afectada por
el conflicto entre el ejército Turco y
el partido de los de los de los
trabajadores del del kurdistán son zonas
alejadas y y las y las condiciones pues
siguen siendo muy graves Además de que
no se ha respetado los reglamentos de
construcción en en Antioquia como hemos
visto cayó un gran edificio muy nuevo
muy muy moderno Nanda Torre mil personas
que murieron ahí en un edificio que se
suponía a prueba del terremotos Sí eso
es así una de las grandes críticas a las
autoridades turcas por este código de
construcción cuando están en un país que
tiene una gran tradición sísmica está en
una de las zonas donde confluyen tres
grandes placas y constantemente Pues a
estos movimientos telúricos no es una
novedad pero Laura usted tocaba el tema
de Siria Y sí creo que es acertado decir
que que Siria tal vez ha estado un poco
ensombrecida por por la tragedia que
está viviendo la vecina Turquía que tal
vez es el país que más ha cargado con
más muertos más ciudades arrasadas pero
la devastación en Siria también es Clara
pero tal vez el análisis que uno puede
hacer es que nos acordamos otra vez de
Siria no volvimos a hablar de Siria que
es un país que tiene un frente abierto
de guerra como lo dice temoris tiene
zonas controladas por Rebeldes tal vez
el mundo se acordó que este conflicto
sigue abierto que sigue habiendo
disputas allí enfrentamientos y que
sigue habiendo muertes
desplazados y una crisis humanitaria
Pues esperemos que sí que el mundo se
acuerde nada más de que hay una crisis
humanitaria acá pero por ejemplo estaba
viendo que en el observatorio sirio para
los Derechos Humanos reportaba hoy el
primer convoy de ayuda humanitaria
y no es tan grande eran básicamente 14
camiones con cobijas alimentos bueno
vestidos lo básico de atención
humanitaria entonces también es muy
complicado porque siento que el mundo
hoy tiene dificultades para ubicar
políticamente su empatía no y que está
digamos gran polarización que está
teniendo
el mundo especialmente el mundo
occidental por la guerra en Ucrania
digamos por el conflicto también en
medio oriente
alrededor de la invasión rusa con la
todos los temas Por eso te decía esta
mañana que los tres temas que tenemos
hoy en realidad son uno solo
no es tan claro Digamos si la empatía la
vamos a colocar en los lugares correctos
o si el mundo va a poder recuperar la
empatía humanitaria digamos de una
manera
equitativa independiente Sí además que
esa esa empatía la ve uno también tal
vez por como se han jugado estos países
en la escena internacional Turquía es un
país que ha buscado jugar un ser un
actor importante relacionándose con
diferentes sectores Siria pues ha
quedado encajado en su en su tema de la
guerra muy metido en su tema interno y
poco relacionamiento tiene con el mundo
exterior ahí ve uno quienes ayudan aquí
en Rusia desplegó tropas y rescatistas
en el norte de Siria pero los otros
países no es que el tema de Turquía
llama mucho la atención porque incluso
países con los que no tiene relación
como por ejemplo Armenia envió ayuda
mientras que Siria no ha recibido
todavía ayuda suficiente tal vez el
temor de los gobiernos es no Mostrar
simpatía por los Rebeldes o por los
kurdos o por el gobierno cómo lo ves
exactamente y yo creo que un poco es
como operar digamos la ayuda humanitaria
teniendo la guerra en Ucrania yo creo
que ese es el gran temor y otro damos
cosas que de parte de la Unión Europea
Pues hay ciertas tensiones hoy mucho más
que antes Entonces por ejemplo la
entrada de Suecia o la repetición de
entrada de Suecia la otan eso no había
pasado antes y eso pasa también se
termina favoreciendo erdogan porque
Suecia Era uno de los países que era
mucho más amable con los refugiados
sirios digamos que tenía una política de
recepción importante de refugiados
sirios eso no va a pasar entonces la
gente que por la guerra por el terremoto
termine huyendo del país o termina
refugiada va a estar realmente maniatada
claro su opinión sobre este juego
internacional de cómo se están moviendo
las fichas y cómo se está dando esta
ayuda internacional
Bueno yo creo
el como como ya me había mencionado
Laura Pues estamos están en Turquía en
la ruta hacia la asociación presidencial
el presidente
erdogan es un sobreviviente es un
político que ha sabido manipular las
grandes divisiones que hay en la
sociedad turca para para su beneficio y
ahora la cuestión es que es si va a
bueno está ha sido sujeto de críticas
porque la ayuda está tardando en llegar
a ciertas zonas hay partes en donde se
denuncia que todavía no hay equipos de
rescatistas pero por el otro lado
dada su habilidad para la manipulación
política Pues él intentará llevar esto
obviamente a su molino y también pues
intentará
aprovechar estas condiciones él él
manipuló todo el tema de los refugiados
tibios para presionar a Europa para
obtener concesiones por Europa de la
misma forma en que en que ha la entrada
de Suecia y de Finlandia a la otan para
tratar de obtener la deportación de
exiliados kurdos que están en esos
países vamos a ver si si esta vez logra
de nuevo hacer este juego este juego de
de de de de cartas que se hace con las
vidas con el sufrimiento de muchísima
gente para lograr su reelección temories
cree usted que este desastre natural
causado por este terremoto sobre todo en
el norte de Siria Esto va a generar una
nueva oleada de migrantes de ciudadanos
sirios tratando de llegar al territorio
europeo a través del territorio Turco
también como puede capitalizar esto el
presidente sirio bachar a la Sad
Aprovechando que está teniendo otra vez
visibilidad internacional Cómo puede
capitalizar esto para bien y para mal
porque aquí se puede usar para
cualquiera de los dos lados
logró de hecho ha ganado la guerra en su
país O sea aunque existen estos estos
pequeños fragmentos del territorio que
están bajo control ajeno pues ha logrado
estabilizar damas con homes
jama y y alepo que son las ciudades
principales entonces usted la ha ganado
la guerra lo que necesita es recuperar
ese territorio que está actualmente en
manos de otros y Pos posiblemente pueda
lograr por ejemplo la La retirada de las
tropas turcas en la medida en que
Turquía va a tener que concentrarse en
la reconstrucción y en la atención a sus
propios
damnificados el el tema también es que
hay cientos de miles de refugiados
sirios en Turquía que dependen de la
ayuda exterior que dependen
del apoyo del gobierno Turco y de la
ayuda internacional y ahora
naturalmente va a tratar de canalizar
ese esa ayuda pues a sus a sus electores
no a la gente que lo Entonces esto muy
seguramente va a empeorar las las
condiciones existentes en los campos de
refugiados sirios en Turquía y también
los campos de refugiados en Siria porque
como sabemos por ejemplo están estos
estos Campos en donde han encerrado a
miles de personas relacionadas con el
grupo terrorista estado islámico y y
escapes de ahí pero también otras
personas Pues están viándose más
afectadas por esas condiciones Entonces
sí es probable que el deterioro de las
condiciones de los refugiados ellos en
Turquía y en Siria provoquen una salida
hacia Europa claro y aquí tienen digamos
la sartén por el mango estos dos
presidentes para presionar por ejemplo a
Europa Laura como lo vio usted pues no
quisiera ser yo Europa en este momento
porque son dos presiones complicadas
también es muy probable que del lado
ruso veamos se busque utilizar
políticamente esta situación no O para
Resaltar el tradicional discurso ruso de
la hipocresía de occidente
o bien digamos para Resaltar el problema
de los migrantes el tema complicado es
que Europa había renunciado al problema
de los migrantes lo había sustituido con
otro problema que era los refugiados
ucranianos sin embargo los refugiados de
Ucrania no fueron tantos y no en las
mismas condiciones digamos ni en los
mismos retos de integración que los
refugiados sirios y esto los va a volver
a poner de frente con esa situación
Entonces no pueden tratar siquiera con
el país de origen digamos de las
personas refugiadas no tienen suficiente
capacidad porque toda la capacidad se
está volcando a la guerra en Ucrania lo
poco que se va a dar desde la Unión
Europea va a estar orientado a la
reconstrucción de Turquía y se va a
generar una olla a presión digamos de
frustración y de rabia que va a terminar
alimentando justamente esa narrativa
rusa de la hipocresía occidental claro
para el cierre de este tema para avanzar
con nosotros que tenemos en la agenda la
misma pregunta para los dos Esto va a
afectar en algo el conflicto en Ucrania
porque hay que recordar que Turquía ha
sido importante interlocutor y puente
entre kiev y Moscú ha ofrecido ancara y
Estambul para mesas de diálogo entre las
partes y ha sido Pues también un país
que ha jugado una un papel importante
para la salida de los cereales cuando
han salido de territorio ucraniano a
través del del bósforo de territorio
Turco ha sido un país importante en este
conflicto y Bueno también hay que
decirlo le vende drones al ejército
ucraniano que es con el que también se
están defendiendo con esos con esos
equipos en la región del Don Bach
comienzo con la ronda la inversa con
Laura entonces para preguntarle si esto
va a afectar en algo por lo menos a
nivel diplomático yo creo que Rusia esto
Turquía va a pasar de ser un país muy
importante un país súper importante
entonces va a traer recursos y pues
obviamente
erdogan va a saber aprovecharlos muy
bien
es posible digamos que adquiera más
también pero también digamos yo yo no
estaría muy segura pero creo que una de
las posibilidades es que en el marco de
la reconstrucción se pierda el esfuerzo
que se ha hecho Vamos como
desescalamiento entre Rusia y Ucrania o
esos esfuerzos de mediación de
negociación básicamente por capacidad
entonces tendría afectarse mucho más el
conflicto allí y eso también va ligado a
sí erdogan continúa de presidente en las
elecciones de morir su análisis para el
cierre Bueno si yo yo no creo que tenga
un impacto importante o medible en el en
el en el papel que juega Turquía de
conflicto Turquía es un país grande es
importante tiene una economía muy sólida
este con problemas económicos con
devaluaciones de la de la de la moneda
pero digamos que esto estos terremotos
no no van a a a a a afectar el el las
capacidades del país si lo si lo colocan
en el centro de la atención pero eso ya
lo había logrado el presidente erdon
sobre todo con el del ingreso de la otan
y también porque pues Turquía está
proveyendo Ucrania de esta tecnología
militar de de estos drones que han que
han sido sumamente eficaces en la en la
guerra y que ya habían proprobado su
eficacia en el conflicto que hubo hace
un par de años entre azerbaiyán y
Armenia porno caravaggio Entonces yo yo
creo que él va a seguir jugando sus
cartas como como lo ha hecho hasta ahora
el presidente erdon y y los ochenta
millones de habitantes que tiene Turquía
sin duda pueden hacer frente a una
tragedia que que deja muchísimos Muertos
pero que es
estadísticamente menor en comparación
con la población del país claro y hay
que decir que el motor económico Turco
está en la zona del centro de anatolia y
en la zona donde está la ciudad de
Estambul Entonces el sur que fue la zona
más afectada al sur este del país pues
no tiene tantos inconvenientes por lo
menos en términos económicos excelente
análisis de lo que puede suceder
entonces en torno a la situación de
Turquía y Siria vamos a pasar a otro
tema destacado de esta semana y tiene
que ver con el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden que presentó su segundo
discurso del estado de la unión muchos
calificaron el discurso como un mensaje
con muchos tintes populistas habló de
sus logros en la generación de empleo
también criticó al sector empresarial en
particular a las farmacéuticas también
criticó por supuesto a la oposición a
los republicanos y volvió a mencionar
algunos puntos básicos sobre migración
política exterior sobre todo frente al
tema de China y Ucrania habló de la
necesidad de combatir el consumo de
fentanilo que es un gran problema para
la sociedad estadounidense y de mantener
el sistema de salud y muchos dicen que
dejó claro o por lo menos dejó una
ventana abierta para entender el tema de
la reelección en dos años entonces pues
comienzo preguntándole a temories para
hacer la ronda la inversa tenemos Joe
para un segundo mandato que Qué
sensación le dejó Usted ese ese discurso
temoris pues parece que él sí lo está
buscando o sea si si ha mostrado antes
interés y este discurso pues ha tratado
de defender su gestión durante durante
este periodo que es la mitad de su
mandato Entonces sí está intentando
enfocar las las baterías hacia una
reelección que eso les convenga los
demócrates probablemente no porque
también parece que
Donald Trump no tiene la energía para
para intentar otra vez una carrera
presidencial y que o sea no no le no le
dan las canicas para para lograr la la
nominación de su partido y y no es lo
mismo que vayan se enfrente a un Trump
que es tan divisivo que obliga a todos
los que son anti Trump a alinearse
juntos con él a que a que se enfrente
por ejemplo a un rol de Santi es el
gobernador de de Florida que es más
joven tiene un discurso menos revisivo
si radical de derechas pero no es Donald
Trump Entonces
se ve difícil que biden pudiera ganar
una
ganarle a alguien como como de Santi es
alguien que no sea Trump y yo creo que
lo asumo que tendrán que buscar una
alternativa Laura y su impresión tenemos
biden para una reelección yo En eso
estoy de acuerdo con temores no creo que
haya para una reelección pero
fundamentalmente Exacto porque la
energía no le va a dar
y él tampoco es capaz de mover la
emoción demócrata digamos él no ha sido
un presidente que emoción entonces justo
en el discurso de la unión estaba viendo
cuánta gente lo vio lo vio muy poquita
gente entonces de los de los discursos
de la unión creo que es el segundo que
menos gente ha visto superado por el
primero que también lo dio él Entonces
no es no es un presidente emocionante No
ni tampoco ni por un lado ni por el otro
no los llama pero a mí me sorprendió lo
doméstico que fue el discurso fue muy
doméstico y eso quiere decir que está
intentando concentrarse en el gran
problema para los norteamericanos hoy
que es la inflación como si la economía
entonces la economía la economía la
economía la inflación todavía está muy
cara y el trabajo y el empleo y mucho
menos en los asuntos exteriores la
menciona China y Ucrania fue una mención
supremamente marginal y bueno temas que
siempre habían estado como en la lupa de
los presidentes de Estados Unidos sobre
todo frente América Latina completamente
desaparecida no sé si temores tiene la
misma impresión sí no aparecimos de
América Latina no ha existido para esta
administración más allá de pronto el
problema migratorio con Centroamérica
temor hizo usted qué piensa
Sí bueno
nosotros estamos ahí solamente para para
como México en este caso como guardia
fronterizo de los Estados Unidos O sea
por lo menos con México han hablado y
han ido a hacer visitas y van y vienen
entre México y Washington a Suramérica
no ha venido a nada
Sí sí porque definitivamente yo yo creo
que también eso es un error estratégico
porque
abandonar América del Sur significa
dejarle el camino abierto el tablero
abierto a China y China no lo está
desperdiciando China está haciendo todo
lo posible por instalarse por instalar
en Brasil y en otros países Entonces es
un es un error de ellos pero también es
que Estados Unidos ya no es el mismo ya
no tiene las capacidades la Cumbre de
las de las Américas que que hubo en Los
Ángeles el año paspas pasado el
presidente López Obrador el presidente
de México le le puso Pues un un
obstáculo grande a biden porque le dijo
ya Estados Unidos no puede determinar
Quiénes pertenecen a la comunidad
continental y Quienes no O sea no puede
decir no invitamos a Nicaragua aunque
sea una dictadura terrible o a Venezuela
o o a Cuba este
unilateralmente Entonces el presidente
no fue y varios países varios
mandatarios de América del Sur siguieron
esta línea que habían puesto el
presidente López Obrador y finalmente
aquí se dijo que esto iba a a poner en
peligro la relación que tenemos con
Estados Unidos pero ya vimos acabamos de
tener aquí a los a los presidentes de
Canadá y de Estados Unidos y fue toda
una escenificación de amistad y de y de
y de Encanto entonces tres amigos
titularon esta Cumbre No sí los fríos no
pero yo creo que en ese aspecto pues
este el ya Estados Unidos no es ese y
tiene que que jugar también en otro
nivel ya ya no puede imponerle cosas al
resto del continente Laura que vienen
para estos dos años que restan del
mandato de biden después de este
discurso Qué sensación le dejó Pues a mí
me dejan lo mismo un baiden mucho más
doméstico más concentrado en resolver
asuntos internos
es un biden que intenta tirarle líneas a
también a los republicanos porque en el
discurso resaltó muchísimo y que me
pareció muy curioso los logros del
bipartidismo norteamericano yo creo que
de alguna manera está teniendo
digamos quiere quiere un Estados Unidos
mucho más tranquilo y quiero en Estados
Unidos mucho menos polarizado entonces
va a buscar también puentes de unidad
ahí incluso con un sector de del partido
republicano creo que no nos va a poner
nada de atención lo digo a ti sí temores
Pero
obviamente a nosotros nos va a poner muy
poquita atención y eso también se va a
reflejar mucho primero en la ayuda
digamos que no creo que vaya a disminuir
pero creo que va a ser una ayuda mucho
menos condicionada y segundo que ya era
un cambio que se veía en la guerra
contra las drogas ahí el cambio de
Estados Unidos va a ser
impresionante que no intervenir en las
decisiones de los países especialmente
nosotros los que tenemos economías
productoras de hoja de coca en Cómo
solucionamos ese tema o en Incluso si lo
solucionamos realmente cuando ya además
hay llamados en la región para cambiar
la política por ejemplo el presidente
Petro pues ha sido una abanderado
diciendo que la la lucha antidrogas
hasta lo que se ha hecho no ha
funcionado el presidente habló del tema
del fentanilo es muy grave el tema del
fentanilo en la frontera con México y es
grave esa situación a nivel sanitario
pero para ir cerrando entonces este tema
impresiones que dejen de lo del sistema
de salud yo me atrevería a decir que ese
coqueteo que le hacen a los republicanos
es aprovechando justamente una fractura
dentro de los republicanos Tal vez
pensándolo así como lo vete moris Bueno
pues el partido republicano tiene el
enorme problema de Qué hacer con el con
el tropismo porque el tropismo es
fundamentalmente algo antisistémico ha
venido a romper la estabilidad interna
del del partido republicano y se ha
convertido en un lastre o sea toda
Aunque todas las trampa esté pasando por
malos tiempos no se puede descartar que
llegue a ser el candidato de este
partido y le ha costado mucho ha acabado
con con la con la coherencia política de
los principales dirigentes republicanos
y lo hay y lo ha arrastrado hacia el
extremo en Estados Unidos históricamente
las elecciones se ganan por el centro
acercándose al centro y Donald Trump los
los ha arrastrado Entonces ellos ellos
son conscientes de este problema biden
también sabe que tienen ese ese problema
y también sabe que necesita que el
sector digamos moderado del partido
republicano logre tener alcanzar alguna
independencia del trompismo para poder
negociar con los demócratas Y tratar de
sacar al menos una parte de su agenda
legislativa para el cierre de este tema
Laura últimas impresiones sobre este
tema de los republicanos divididos el
fentanilo el tema de seguridad Sí y de
salud pues a mí me parece que lo del
fentanilo fue supremamente inteligente
por parte de biden primero porque
digamos el fentanilo ocupa el lugar que
antes ocupaba la cocaína en la en el
imaginario conservador de las familias
digamos que le votan al partido
republicano que están muy preocupados
por la gente que viene a envenenar sus
niños y sus casas le quitó ese pedacito
del discurso a Trump pero sin meterse en
una camisa de 11 varas con la comunidad
internacional porque finalmente el
fentanilo no es la cocaína y la guerra
contra las drogas se creó alrededor de
la cocaína y de la marihuana Entonces es
muy estratégico el uso de la palabra
para coquetear con los sectores más
conservadores de la sociedad digamos que
pudieran
apoyarle por lo menos alejarse del
trompismo en las próximas elecciones y
para ser beter esa que su sistema de
salud como lo quiere mantener
fortalecido puede dar una respuesta
eventualmente a esa a ese problema de
salud que está presentando Estados
Unidos pues dejamos el tema del
presidente biden y su discurso de lado
avanzamos con otro tema de la agenda
porque esta semana lo comentamos también
ampliamente en buena parte de los medios
a nivel internacional y fue esa gira del
presidente de Ucrania bology mercedesky
estuvo en las ciudades de Londres en
París y también en Bruselas en una
Cruzada por pedir más ayuda militar
logística y económica para hacer frente
a las tropas rusas que invadieron el
territorio ucraniano el presidente de
ese país del este de Europa logra
entonces mantener justamente el apoyo
europeo en términos logísticos y
militares a pesar de que por ejemplo la
primera ministra de Italia Georgia
meloni no le gustó que macron y shows se
reunieran por su cuenta con el
presidente dijo que la Unión Europea
pues tenía que manejarse como un bloque
y que ellos se habían tomado decisiones
casi que de manera unilateral con y no
tenían una posición común para
determinar por ejemplo el posible
suministro de avión escasa a las fuerzas
militares ucranianas entre tanto las
ciudades de kiev saporilla y harquive
han recibido los mayores ataques contra
su infraestructura crítica esta semana
dejaron varias víctimas mortales varios
civiles allí en estos ataques en medio
de estos ataques justamente dos misiles
lanzados por Rusia violaron el espacio
aéreo de moldavia y de Rumanía este
último país hay que recordar es
integrante de la otan el gobierno
moldabo en kitchenau confirmó la
violación de su espacio aéreo condenó
enérgicamente el hecho Mientras que el
gobierno rumano en bucarest aseguró que
el proyectil pasó 35 kilómetros de su
frontera común con Ucrania vamos
entonces a las impresiones Laura comenzó
con usted para hacer la ronda la inversa
ya pidió tanques pidió armas sistemas
antimisiles ahora va por los casas y
dijo yo soy europeo soy más europeo que
cualquier europe
recíbanme por favor en esta casa digamos
Ucrania es Europa prácticamente Y eso es
supremamente importante porque no solo
pidió ayuda militar digamos pidió el
consenso de la Unión Europea digamos de
facto ya la Unión Europea tiene consenso
en condenar a Rusia y tiene consenso en
apoyar de diversas maneras porque los
países tienen distintos tonos y
temperaturas en el apoyo a Ucrania
entonces mientras los nórdicos dicen
bueno recibimos los refugiados vamos a
darlo todo en ayuda humanitaria pronto
en la reconstrucción pues Francia tiene
una posición digamos decir voy a dar
ayuda militar él quiere que toda Europa
ayude militar O sea que toda Europa lo
acompañe en la guerra yo no estoy segura
si eso es posible pero ha sido el
discurso más emotivo que alguien ha dado
vamos recientemente en el parlamento
europeo vamos a ver si logró mover las
fibras de los europeos que ya también
muchos están cansando vamos para un año
de guerra y también hay muchas
dificultades dentro de los países y que
sumar el terremoto de Turquía entonces
Ucrania y ellos su importancia empieza a
acercarse si empieza a acercarse a un
abismo temorís como lo ve
Pues mira yo yo creo que el problema de
los europeos y en general de lo de de la
otan es que tanto es tantito como como
se dice en México no sé si en Colombia
también pero qué tanto es tantito o sea
hasta dónde pueden ellos Elevar su apoyo
a Ucrania sin provocar una que que la
que la guerra se salga de las de las de
las fronteras de Ucrania el año pasado
cayó un misil en Polonia y los los
polacos se se apresuraron a decir que no
que no pasaba nada que no eran que lo
que los rusos no tenían la culpa los
ucranianos dijeron que por supuesto que
sí tenía la culpa ahora es este es este
otro que habría sobrevolado territorio
de Rumanía según Ucrania y y no nada más
de moldavia según
Rumanía él el tema es que un ataque
directo contra un país de la otan que
Rumanía y Polonia son de la otan podría
provocar una esca incontrolable en la
isla guerra que llegue hace unos hasta
no sabemos dónde ya ya Putin varias
veces a ha mencionado la posibilidad de
una guerra nuclear del o del o del uso
de armas no no
sería gravísimo Entonces el el ese es el
problema siempre hasta dónde pueden
escalar las cosas sin que se salga de
control el el la Aviación rusa pues ha
fracasado gravemente en el en tomar el
control del de los de los cielos de
Ucrania se esperaba que lo tuvieran no
lo han conseguido el un un la llegada de
aviones casa de en apoyo a Ucrania Pues
sería
provocaría un movimiento en el en el en
el balance de la de la guerra gravemente
en contra de Rusia y podría
generar una respuesta todavía más grave
mayor además que me atrevería yo bueno
sin ser parte la Unión Europea sin ser
líder de ningún país me atrevería a
decir que también muchos piden
resultados piden no solamente los
avances de las tropas y mayor
confrontación mayor despliegue de tropas
armas todo pero también que kiev muestra
de pronto alguna posibilidad de
negociación con con Moscú o le toque la
puerta a Moscú por lo menos para ver al
final del túnel una pequeña luz al
conflicto porque esto se está alargando
más de lo que todo el mundo pensaba y
Tal parece que el diálogo no está ahí
Laura no está no está el diálogo no no
está y desafortunadamente digamos Europa
tiende a pedir resultados muy rápido
primero pensó que esto iba a ser una
guerra muy corta que era una invasión
digamos que Putin no iba a ser capaz de
llegar más allá semanas después dijo
Bueno esto Tal vez va a ser un conflicto
de medio término y ahora está diciendo
nos tenemos en casa que preparar para un
conflicto de larga intensidad con todo
lo que eso implica para el estilo de
vida europeos y llegan más refugiados y
no llegan más Que tanto se mantiene bajo
control y bajo frontera la confrontación
como realmente vamos a reaccionar vamos
a dar apoyo militar o no vamos a dar
apoyo militar incluso cosas impensables
como por ejemplo países nórdicos en la
otan es que eso realmente fue un salto
que hace 30 años era completamente
imposible Entonces es digamos hay una
presión también muy fuerte de cierto
sector de la ciudadanía europea
para digamos ganar mucho más
militarmente digamos para una política
de mano dura claro Bueno pues se me va
acabando ya el tiempo para el programa
para el cierre sé que este tema de
Ucrania nos da para muchísimo más para
analizar pero quiero preguntarle primero
a temories dejo a Laura para el cierre
del programa los temas a los que van a
estar poniéndole la mira poniendo la
lupa para el análisis la siguiente
semana si tienen algo ya en remojo de
los temas que van a trabajar para que
nos vayan aquí contando un poco de la
agenda de lo que podemos tener los
próximos días
Bueno yo creo que que el tema Ucrania va
a seguir concentrando la la atención
Ellos tienen que decidir van a darle
aviones y otro tipo de tecnología de
Avanzada a Ucrania o no y también qué es
lo que va a pasar adentro de Rusia Cuál
es el el nivel de de consenso que puede
asegurarse Putin no solamente para
sostener su de su esfuerzo bélico sino
para mantenerse el mismo en el en el
gobierno ese es un tema ese es un
problema existencial para para el
presidente Putin porque podrá él pasar a
la historia como como el el gran héroe
ruso que recuperó su influencia o
terminará en la cárcel rápidamente Laura
para el cierre sus temas Pues a mí me
encantaría decir que el tema de la
semana va a ser la segunda Ronda de
diálogos con el eln que ocurre ahí en tu
casa temories pero creo que no no va a
pasar estoy de acuerdo con temoris que
en la próxima semana vamos a tener mucho
más sobre este conflicto entre uc y
Rusia y también sobre la reconstrucción
de Siria sobre los rescates y es muy
posible que se generen muchas protestas
También tenemos sobre la distribución de
la ayuda humanitaria eso también está
sobre la mesa temorice Laura les
agradezco muchísimo haber estado con
nosotros rápidamente despido el programa
porque se me acaba el tiempo les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
sigan en sintonía de France 24
[Música]